pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing
company dedicated to making the very
best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6
built-a-wear
not to wear out visit grip6.compogchamps
i get to meet rain he's amazing dude
do you want to play like irl
yeah and make out too
come on now come
[Music]
in this match i'm not really sure what
to expect um
but i do expect the games to be pretty
close look good i just got a shot into
bobby hall's
outfit he's just like oh wow
it's isn't that looks like something
right out of the 1970s
but he's dressed like dwight from the
office true that's true
i literally literally
last night and said wait till you see my
outfit but i had no idea this was what
he was going to do this is hilarious
oh my god yeah all right well here you
go everybody we've got rayne wilson
versus dwight schrute
and this is going to be this is going to
be epics
dwight you're dwight schrute against
logic
do i shoot against logic is what it
should be yep um you just said rayne
wilson against dwight shirt well because
he just said you know ray wilson's
playing playing dwight schrute here oh
sorry
oh you're riffing off that sorry okay
okay yeah yeah
anyway that's hilarious and uh
we'll see we'll see if rayne notices it
in the post-match interviews regardless
of what happens
but okay exactly yeah apparently he
actually is streaming without a mic i've
just been
so okay oh so he'll be quiet okay so
okay so he's just gonna be quiet for the
whole time
basically well he played d6
and reign quickly played one um yeah
pretty standard so far i would say
nothing really out of the ordinary yeah
the biggest thing
right now this is gonna be such a close
positional game the clock starts to hurt
you
if you're rooting for logic because he's
already down two minutes and
i'm struggling to find a plan here
because like you said d5 is the logical
thing to do
but it's hard to make yourself play it
that's true yeah i mean i i don't know i
don't know what else you do you can play
rookie
d5 you may move the knight and then play
f5 or try to but very very difficult
oh wow look at that he finds it well he
does it very nice
but again i don't think there's any
anything is guaranteed actually he takes
on f3 which is not bad but i think he
has to follow it up with some
some critical moves which won't be easy
like knight h5 maybe or 97 knight she
says knight f4
that h4 is not a bad idea he's trying to
attack but it can also get you in big
trouble here
but then i don't know a knight on the
rim as we say a knight on the rim
is dim or grim um and the knight on the
rim is not really doing anything here
cause it can't go back to f5 because the
bishop covers the f5 square
but it also can't go to f3 so your
knight is kind of out to lunch and you
can't bring it back to the center of the
board
uh very easily but look at this f5 i
like it from
from bobby's perspective he's trying to
justify where all of his pieces are
placed right now right he's looking for
f4 and e4
do something right with all of the all
the king side
pieces that he has i like what i'm
seeing here i felt that
maybe in the first match he's a little
bit more on edge um but he seems like
he's he's been preparing studying and i
think he's doing
doing really well once again brain's
trying to get rid of the pawn on f5
that would be probably a good trade for
him oh h5 oh but it doesn't work here
because
the king comes up but no you still get
mated because
right you get rook g2 and then king h g6
is still checking oh he wanders at h4
logic's gonna see the checkmate i think
he's got mate and two yeah now king g4
and rook g2 is checkmate
i think logic should see rook g2 and
then because he creates a new picture as
xqc said then he should see g6
unbelievable logic again loki has been a
guy who's been crushing and working on
his chess i mean
he's got lessons he takes regularly and
he he's been playing
this is a guy that might be surprising
people as as a potential favorite oh my
god look at him clean that up
what a game from black so beautiful
okay the next game begins so not too
much time to talk about it we've got e4
on the board rain playing his his pierce
that he played
but one tip i gave him after playing the
losing tactic against tubbo that he got
away with with bishop g4 i said don't
play bishop g4 right
rain don't play bishop g4 here
oh oh i'm sure he won't right okay we
went over it that was after he played on
day two that was the only thing we went
over i said
and i still don't play you got away with
murder there um
okay he didn't play it good call
i'm actually very concerned for rayne
wilson i found it whoa he played it wow
did he really just see that pawns not
under attack i find it hard to believe
that he
might have gotten or
yeah i think he got lucky kind of like
xqc got lucky against daniel leguano
like xqc did not see the idea with
bishop takes b5 in the discover check
um but then once he got there he figured
it out i feel like rayne probably didn't
even realize his pawn is
oh and oh and logic takes it oh no oh
man
well i think rain is going to win this
game we're headed to our our
our megadon which is funny i think rain
rain will be the only player who's
played two armageddon matches for sure
the one he had with michelle care is
that is that still the only armageddon
we've had or have we had others
i think that's the only only one we've
had wow
okay so probably just rookie 8 here and
i think yeah i think this one's going to
be over pretty soon
save the rook give a check
but yeah this should be straightforward
now and and yeah i think we're arma
armor get it on doesn't armageddon oh
there's no it's our megadon or megadon
armageddon
i mean a logic can play h5 to stop it
but it's it's not
it's not really going to change anything
in the situation
yeah f5 was good he gets his king out
but like you said couldn't change it
and sort of uh yeah just bishop takes h4
and uh and yeah rain's gonna win this
game we're gonna have
have another one by the way however with
this being a um
what was that right i was gonna say
what is what is rook f3
okay yeah okay now he has queen e4 to uh
to finish off the game
24 is a good stylistic move just
just pick up the pick up a pony
fun fact chess was invented at the shoot
farms uh that was a great line for us
yeah greeted me diamond membership that
was hilarious
um all right queen e4 come on rain
there you go any fines now not the
blunder king h3 queen f4 that's the only
thing
that would be stalemate yes and less
than ideal still based steven
right yep so i think the idea is yeah
you
i think for rain though it's pretty easy
you take with the rook and then you just
do the ladder with queenie three work up
two queen f1
well remember bobby's already been still
mated once in the event right
yeah so it's true he really should have
played king h3 there i think i think
that
um yeah that would have been his chance
that was a good call
he didn't see it
and now rain will play rook h2 or queen
f3 rook f3 some combination of the win
waiting exactly yeah holding old
yep holding
yeah we're still waiting what's he doing
holding
okay he's doing the other one he's doing
the reverse ladder
he's just doing queen e3 and rook four
so we will actually have armageddon done
in the final game in the final match all
right sorry we have one more match don't
worry
we got hbc pokey after this too for sure
right right right exactly so oh man yeah
so we get our
our our arm armageddon i screwed you up
armageddon
yeah exactly yeah all right all right
everyone don't go anywhere
hey carl and i be back with megatron and
the whole crew is coming back we got
bumblebee
we got shyla buff it's arma get it on
pog champ's style and okay here we go
final game five minutes to four minutes
or mega dome
okay pretty standard so far let's see
what's gonna happen
it should be five probably bishop c5 i
assume
okay also it's gonna say the logic has
been pretty slow yeah that
that's a good point and maybe that's
part of why rayne chose yeah chose white
to take advantage of the clock true
this is the armageddon game so white has
to win here rain has to win
bobby wins on both a draw and a loss
oh wow look at these pawns here i mean
yeah he's trying to create the wall here
on on the fourth rank uh he's already
got three of them
at some point you can maybe push d4 and
gotta get a get a big wall
so um really really good position for
rayne wilson here
but it's funny because it's one that
could backfire right because obviously
it's very good especially if you know
someone like you is playing but it's one
of those positions where
if he doesn't convert on it his king is
going to be wide open and that could
lead to a draw
right exactly yeah very true so after g5
probably 97
i mean maybe rook the eighth here um
knight a3 is a really good move though
by um
by rayne wilson to go knight c4 yeah he
needed to get developed
and and coming to c4 i can't highlight
apparently
um
yeah that's his place and now just like
queen of three and rook d1 just sits on
the the great wall
of peshka
not the great wall of china anyway
so the great wall of peshka okay now
he's gonna have f5
here yeah if i was just winning here for
white i think
um anyway good
[Laughter]
yeah yeah oh we played it you played at
five
yeah he's crushing it here
yeah rain is just crushing it in this
game he's playing really really well
very very smooth game from from rain
you can bring the queen out
bring the queen out you can also maybe
just move his king over okay knight c6 i
like but at the same time
yeah i i don't know there's 27
no i'm with you yeah he goes back to e5
so now he's probably just mopping it up
but you're right though because the risk
if he loses his focus somehow let's not
forget all this queen needs is a queen
g5 or a queen g3
and and a draw remember wins the game
for bobby so rain has to be careful i i
would love to have seen him play like
queen of three and rook d1
it's not over as long as bobby has a
chance for some checks
right exactly yeah yeah this is uh but
overall
very very good game from rain i mean i
think certainly we've been talking up
like one of the favorites but the way
that he's playing um
the way he's playing this game has been
incredible and now just he just does not
take on g6 that would be a
i mean it's still winning but that would
be start to create problems because
right now he's no
no shelter around his king he's got a
bunch of pawns that are being pushed up
the board
yeah queen out oh okay finally he does
it queen f3 is a really good sign
you can put the king on h1 or h2 as said
and then maybe use the g file for his
rook
yeah this is i mean really really good
for uh for rain he's playing this is
just a model game from rain
model game
okay very very very good
luck's getting closer together i don't
even know what to say it's just breaking
although
what's the time the time is getting
close let's look at the time it's only
20 seconds for rain
and remember there's no increment in
this one guys that's it's no longer
ten plus five this is the time you see
is the time they get
no help cut right it's straight up you
just you straight up no increment
i mean if rain gets down on the clock
i'm not sure he's gonna win this yeah
we're down to what one minute about
both players getting i mean rain is
about to be down on the clock he's it's
very close
he allowed that check i don't know and
that's a check that's a check
uh-oh okay oh 94 oh my gosh this is
getting wild gosh
oh bobby had 94.
you missed it but he's got to keep going
there's just no panic just keep going
oh no yeah and now he sees now he plays
chess too late
we have six queen of six queen f6 we
have six and remember
bobby wins on a draw as long as brain's
king is open this is not over
yeah bobby just has to move you're just
moving you hope you just
he's going full kambakaze yeah
that was not his most logical move
right there's one last hope if if
knight f7 though wait knight f7 is a
fork right oh owie 97 is game over yeah
or rook g1 as long as he doesn't allow
queen g2 here
oh wow he finds work g1
beautiful move by rayne very well played
i think i think you're right i think
he's going to get it now for sure
wow yeah and also yeah i mean bobby just
kind of he kind of collapsed under
pressure when they both
had no time um but again it's an
armageddon game so any anything goes
kind of in a way
although could there be a stalemate
there's probably not because
there's a still yeah but based on where
the pawns are there's no style mate
too many pawns that can be pushed four
pawns and also you saw that uh logic
just he started clapping so
uh he's basically conceded defeat here
yep all out of check
as long as reign checks there he goes
yeah
right we're going to have interviews
with both these guys can't wait to talk
to uh logic about his outfit with rayne
wilson
um identity theft is a crime bobby what
do you have to say about your outfit
yeah it i i like my outfit
i thought it would be kind of funny and
i hope it wouldn't be taken the wrong
way i thought he'd get the joke and
yeah it's awesome i think you look
incredibly handsome rayne do you want to
say anything about the terrible coach
you have or anything do you want to
get that off your chest or or no
you're the worst i am the worst you're
the worst okay you've known bobby for
years you didn't even prepare me for him
and um you always talk about like this
idea of outpost nights which i'm kind of
just starting to learn about but his
night being there just screwed me yeah i
was just
destroyed once he got his night there i
was just when i say
i was [__]
i just couldn't do anything and my and
my my rook all the way on the other side
was not helping me and
and then i didn't see this little ploy
you know with him taking my bishop there
and i just i got screwed and he just
it was a masterful game man he just like
it was like the vice just turning and i
couldn't
get out of it thank you it was cool and
like i said this is my first time like
ever competing in anything
so this is just giving me what about rap
battles
i guess so are you telling me you never
saw eight mile
i i was low-key that guy in real life
but yes i did rap battle but it was
mainly in high school
and then i was like [__] this i want to
like
make actual music and that was fun and
now i'm here
getting my ass kicked by rain but
i just wanted to say that even though
you know i lost this
um it was it's a really great experience
and it's gotten me even more excited
about chess
and this whole competition has made me
want to i mean
every day i'm playing every day i'm
doing puzzles every day i'm playing my
rating
is going up and that's exciting so the
fact that we get to do all this and it's
for charity
and like i get to meet rain is amazing
dude do you want to play like irl
yeah and make out too
come on now come on
uh yeah no that would be just to go too
far
well regardless of the result guys you
actually tied for first in your group so
you're both going
to the championship bracket you finish
with seven points a piece
um and um i don't get any are we going
to meet again
i hope i don't have to play him again
it's possible you can meet the final you
won't meet in the first round but it's
possible you could meet in the finals so
this could be uh could be a preview
heck yeah heck yeah baby heck yeah baby
um irl chess soon you were a worthy
opponent man and you play great chess
and thank you
um you were a wily adversary and um
took every every pubic hair i had
any dresses will too sure yes
i do i i think i have the swag it's a
long-sleeve mustard shirt
it is what do you think what are you
doing you need the short sleeve bro
all right maybe i should maybe i should
have done that but yeah thank you as
well
um that was the craziest
game of chess i'd ever played that first
one i mean this whole the whole match
um it was exciting i was nervous you
know my heart was pounding like
but yeah because i just really care
about chess and i really respect you
not only in your profession but as a
player watching these games that you've
been playing
so thank you so much for uh an amazing
oh you're very you're very kind i
respect you as well and i hope we
i hope we meet in the finals man that
will be that will be the battle of the
century
that'd be sick but you guys are both
awesome seriously you gave us you gave
us the match of the day so far heading
to armageddon we wish you guys
the best of luck in the championship
bracket and uh we'll we'll see you then
awesome thank you guys
you